نقل موقع اكسيوس الاخباري عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان الرئيس جو بايدن
ومسؤولين كبار محبطون من رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو لرفضه طلبات
لواشنطن متعلقه بالحرب على غزه وبحسب
هؤلاء المسؤولين فان هناك ادله متزايده
على ان بايدن بدا يفقد صبره تجاه نتنياهو
كما اشاروا الى ان اداره بايدن قالق من ان
اسرائيل لن تلتزم بجدولها للانتقال الى
عمليات اقل حده في غزه وبحسب مصادر اكسيوس
فان زياره وزير الخارجيه انتوني بلينكن
الاخيره لاسرائيل ادت الى تفاقم الاحباط
داخل البيت الابيض وفي الخارجيه الامريكيه
ونقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤول امريكي قوله ان
بلينكن اوضح لنتنياهو ولمجلس وزراء الحرب
ان خطه اسرائيل لليوم التالي حلم لا يمكن
تحقيقه
معنا الان من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره عبد
الفتاح فايد المزيد من التفاصيل لما نشره
موقع اكسيوس
الاخباري نعم ازدهار هذا هذه المواقف من
جانب الاداره الامريكيه في الحقيقه هي
تعكس محاولات امريكيه للابتعاد ولو قليلا
عن الموقف الاسرائيلي الذي باتت الاداره
الامريكيه على ما يبدو تشعر بانها تدفع
ثمنا ضا لهذه المواقف الاسرائيليه وهذه
الحرب التي يرفض رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو ان يوقفها او حتى ان يخفف
من عملياتها العسكريه وفقا للطلبات
الامريكيه المعلنه هذا هذه التصريحات في
الحقيقه وما نقلته وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه تاتي بعد ساعات قليله من انتهاء
واحده من اقوى المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه على
الحرب في غزه هنا في العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن وفقا لتقديرات وسائل الاعلام
المحليه الامريكيه ذاتها وليس لناشطين ا
من المشاركين في تلك المظاهرات فان اعداد
المشاركين بها تجاوزت 100000 امريكي
تظاهروا احتجاجا على هذه الحرب وحملوا
لافتات مندده بالحرب الاسرائيليه وبالدعم
الامريكي وبدعم اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن لهذه الحرب حملوا الصور التي صور
المسؤولين الامريكيين وعلى راسهم الرئيس
الامريكي بايدن ووزير خارجيته انوني
بلينكن وهي ملطخه بالدماء ووصفوا ما يجري
في غزه بانه حرب اباده تجري بدعم امريكي
لا محدود وبدعم امريكي بالمال وبالسلاح
وبالدعم السياسي والدبلوماسي ونددوا بهذا
الدعم الامريكي لاسرائيل
هذه المظاهره التي شهدتها ساحه الحريه في
واشنطن تحولت الى مسيره الى البيت الابيض
واستمرت حتى وقت متاخر حتى من الليل من
الثامنه مساء بتوقيت العاصمه واشنطن وهي
التي بدات في الواحده ظهرا رغم بروده
الطقس بالتاكيد على ما يبدو هذه
الاحتجاجات باتت الاداره الامريكيه تسمعها
جيدا ازدهار وباتت تحاول ان تطمئن الشارع
الامريكي انها ليست على مسافه واحده مع
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
ومجلس الحرب ربما هذا هو التطور الجديد في
الموقف التطور الاخر هو ان وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه التي كانت تتجاهل مثل هذه
الاحتجاجات ولا تكاد تذكرها على الاطلاق
افردت لها مساحات كبيره تقديرات وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه والمحطات الامريكيه لها
بان المشاركه غير مسبوقه في هذه المظاهره
التي تصادف اليوم المئ على الحرب في غزه
هذا هذه ليست المره الاولى في الحقيقه
التي تحاول فيها اداره بايدن ان تتخذ
مسافه عن الموقف الاسرائيلي لكنها ربما
تاتي في ضوء تطورات ملفته سواء على
المستوى الميداني في غزه ومستوى المقاومه
الموجود في غزه او حتى على مستوى
الاحتجاجات في الشارع الامريكي والتي لم
تعد تقتصر على الجاليات الفلسطينيه او
العربيه او الاسلاميه كانت هناك مشاركات
في هذه الاحتجاجات من جانب منظمات يهوديه
معارضه للحرب في غزه من جانب منظمات مثل
حياه السود مهمه كان هناك اعضاء من
الكونجرس يشاركون في هذه الاحتجاجات
وبالتالي ما نقله الان وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه عن الاداره الامريكيه على ما
يبدو هي محاوله من المسؤولين الامريكيين
للابتعاد ولو قليلا وتدريجيا عن الموقف
الاسرائيلي الامر الاخر انهم بداوا يدركون
بان تحقيق اهداف الحرب لم يعد ممكنا وهذا
ما نقالته اكسيوس عن المسؤولين الامريكيين
بان حلم ما بعد الحرب في غزه الذي يتمناه
نتنياهو ومجلس حربه على ما يبدو بعيد
المنال وغير قابل للتح تحقيق وبالتالي عدم
القدره على تحقيق اهداف الحرب حتى الان
سواء فيما يتعلق بالقضاء على حماس حتى
كهدف اولي او حتى فيما يتعلق باستعاده
الرهائن ع عبر العمليات العسكريه كل هذه
الاهداف لم تتحقق وبالتالي يبدو الحديث عن
ما بعد الحرب واحلام ما بعد الحرب على
الرغم من ان المسؤولين الامريكيين لم
يفصحوا عن ماهيه هذه الاحلام ما بعد الحرب
هل هي تتعلق بعمليات تهجير سكان قطاع غزه
كما كان يحلم بعض المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
ويرددون ذلك بالتاكيد الهار لا يمكن ان
نغفل ايضا السياق الدولي المرتبط بهذه
التطورات وفي القلب منه محكمه العدل
الدوليه وجريمه الاباده التي تمثل بها
اسرائيل امام محكمه العدل الدوليه وكذلك
الكثير من التطورات وهذا التعاطف الكبير
او هذا الدعم الكبير من جانب عدد كبير من
دول العالم لموقف جنوب افريقيا والدعوه
التي رفعتها جنوب افريقيا امام محكمه
العدل الدوليه كل هذه التطورات بالتاكيد
هي تحت نظر المسؤولين الامريكيين وتؤثر في
مواقفهم السياسيه ازدهار ن شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره عبد الفتاح
فايد